that is a flat-out live birth we just
asked the next schmuck who walks through
and hey sir hi I really don't care as
long as I get a good cameo call my agent
my favorite cameo and I know everybody
is waiting with bated breath is the one
I didn't look or the or the floor movie
where he won he's having a very potent
drink and I'm standing next to Thor and
I say hey let me have some of that and
he says no you can't drink it it's it's
too strong for you and I can't handle it
so it gives me a drink and in the next
scene they're carrying me out now you're
saying to yourself why is that his
favorite cameo it's no big deal and now
I'm gonna answer that question it's my
favorite cameo you probably didn't think
of this you wouldn't have thought
because it's my only cameo that had two
scenes first me with Thor we don't drink
and then being carried out now I hope
that'll give the various directors and
producers the idea that Stan is more
than a one same kind of guy so if you
didn't see today Stan Lee had a birthday
everyone's been wishing him many happy
returns and Kevin Feige is saying many
many more cameos to come just wishing
him many more birthdays hoping that he
sticks around for a long time so wanted
to do a video for his best cameos as
well as his infinity war cameo and the
cameos that are left to come that he's
already filmed so far so be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'll be
doing a whole bunch of Marvel stuff in
the next couple of weeks because we're
ramping up for Black Panther and I'm
giving away an Infinity Gauntlet replica
that I'll explain at the end of the
video but just to give you an idea for
the scope of things he has at least 32
film cameos not including Black Panther
the next two Avengers films Deadpool -
ant-man and the wasp the Spider Man
homecoming sequel Captain Marvel Dark
Phoenix
maybe the venom movie he didn't create
venom so I don't expect him to have a
cameo in that movie but here we go
montage style then I'll explain what my
favorite Stan Lee cameo is at the end of
this
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm concerned security would it be good
morning dr. breslar security ought to be
beefed up a lot more in a place like
this
welcome back to the Baxter dr. Richards
I've got the usual for you good to have
you back sir thanks Willie
[Music]
you know I guess one person can make a
difference
enough said
[Music]
invitation sir and I should be on that
list name Stanley yeah nice try buddy
really remember me sure don't look great
huh gamma sickness Milwaukee the man
drank one of those guarana sodas guess
it had a little more kick than he was
looking for
[Music]
[Applause]
we're captain that's your cue I thought
he'd be taller
[Music]
superheroes in New York and all the
other worlds would just pass us by
it's beautiful simple bending questions
yeah can I have my show back oh man I am
so fired
look at mr. smiles over in my card
where's your wife oh man what a blast a
griever the barrels built from the wreck
of Broncos fleet is not meant for mortal
men neither was Omaha Beach blondie stop
trying to scare us
egg shell sheer fine right
the bartender's all like yeah
crazy-stupid fine are you Tony
dank yes this is this is Tony stank
[Music]
that is hilarious
Wow nice suit anyway before I was so
rudely interrupted at that time I was a
Federal Express man hey fellas hey wait
where are you going let me know in the
comments what your favorite Stan Lee
cameo is but I feel like most of us
probably love the guardians of the
galaxy watcher cameo the best because it
is the final confirmation of the theory
of Stan Lee cameos in that everything is
connected he is the same person in all
of these cameos he's an agent of The
Watcher sent to watch all these events
and report back to them so that's why
it's my favorite and at the beginning of
the video when he says I hope that some
director figures out that I'm not just a
one scene person James Gunn included him
in two scenes during that watcher cameo
there was the first one in the middle of
the movie and then there was the actual
post-credit scene where they leave him
on that asteroid
but speaking of infinity war what's his
cameo going to be at such a huge movie
we'll remember he actually cameo as a
person on Xander Xander is where the
Power Stone is Thanos needs that he
might be there to witness Stannis coming
to take that stone in a some sort of
funny moment like well time to get out
of here now and he just takes off of the
planet before it gets destroyed so let
me know in the comments what kind of a
cameo do you want him to have during
infinity war but it's either going to be
with Thanos like some big fan of smut
with the Infinity Gauntlet or with the
Avengers when Thanos shows up there's a
new round of that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on the
video congratulations to the winner from
my last video gabriel bloom please
private message me so i can get your
contact details i'll name a new winner
when I post new Avengers so what's
happening is I have some new Game of
Thrones coming up later but you can
click here for my Iron Man Captain
Marvel theory and click here for brand
new Rick and Morty thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you
tonight
[Music]